[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 tout de suite les titres de ce
mercredi 6 septembre
c'est l'une des grandes nouveautés de la
rentrée la mise en place des classes de
cp à 12 élèves dans les écoles des
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire
renforcer les yvelines sont concernés
par ce dispositif décryptage dans cette
édition
il va faire peau neuve le stade jean
maréchal de montigny le bretonneux sera
rénové pendant l'inter saison de
baseball il est l'écrin des cougars
engagé en demi finales des championnats
de france enfin à donner des solutions
clés en main aux entrepreneurs pour
organiser leurs futurs événements
d'entreprise objectifs du premier salon
skymiles dès demain à la ferme du manet
de montigny le bretonneux
pour en parler nous recevons jean michel
fourgous deuxième vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines politique pour
débuter ce journal les élections
sénatoriales ca le 24 septembre prochain
est la république en marche a dévoilé ce
matin la liste de ses candidats dans les
yvelines
huit noms composent cette liste du parti
présidentiel les détails avec mickaël
landreau la république en marche en
ordre de bataille dans les yvelines le
mouvement présenté ce mercredi 6
septembre à versailles six troupes pour
les élections sénatoriales
martin lévriers 54 ans conseiller
municipal versés depuis 2008 et
secrétaire général dans un lycée
polyvalent conduira la liste dont je
compte apporter ma pierre très fortement
au sénat sur la partie professionnelle
que je méprise et bien évidemment sur
mon accroche on approche de terrain
politique auprès des collectivités
territoriales la condition de bertin
vivrières entre très clairement dans la
volonté que nous avons dans un certain
nombre de départements d'offrir aux
grands électeurs le choix de pouvoir
avoir un pari du renouveau de la
jeunesse de la thématique de la
formation d'éducation du crédit de
quelqu'un qui est dans sa profession a
su montrer des réalisations extrêmement
positive
l'homme politique sera accompagné de
sept autres personnes dont michel dupart
issus du modem conseil municipal à
poissy et anne grignon maire sans
étiquette de lévis saint nom la femme
politique était la suppléante de jean
noël barrot lors de sa victoire aux
législatives en juin dernier dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
j'ai toujours trouvé très intéressant de
travailler avec les bonnes volontés des
gens compétents des gens disponibles et
je trouve que le débat démocratique
s'exerce de manière tout à fait
formidable
lorsque nous travaillons avec une
diversité de sensibilité après avoir
raflé onze circonscriptions sur 12 lors
des élections législatives dans le
département vers le public en marche n'a
pour l'instant pas annoncé d'objectifs
chiffrés pour les sénatoriales
l'ensemble des listes pour ces
sénatoriales sera connu ce vendredi
déjà certaines ont été rendues
officielles notamment les listes des
républicains udi modem est également
celle du prg une élue des yvelines
justement de la république en marche ce
matin sur les ondes
aurore bergé était l'invité de la
matinale de rfi la députée de la 10e
circonscription et porte parole du
groupe
lrm à l'assemblée s'est exprimé sur
plusieurs sujets pour elle le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron doit
s'attacher à transformer la france en
ciblant trois crises majeures le chômage
le logement et la dette
aurore bergé a eu également un mot pour
son ancien parti les républicains qui ne
doit pas se restreindre
afin d'être encore une force
d'opposition crédible
sa mort a suscité une forte émotion dans
les yvelines l'ancien maire de chevreuse
claude genot 74 ans est décédé et des
suites d'une longue maladie le 22 août
dernier une semaine après ses obsèques
les élus de la commune doivent d
nier leur nouvel édile conseil municipal
ce soir à 20h and here i le pallec
première adjointe de chevreuse est
pressenti pour prendre la succession de
claude genot c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien et lui
fallait bien inciter ces entrepreneurs à
créer de l'événement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance le sky
my day le premier salon de
l'événementiel sur le territoire c'est
demain de midi à 20 heures à la ferme du
manet de montigny le bretonneux
c'est à destination des collaborateurs
en entreprise agences ou encore
associations et pour en parler de social
maïs deuil avec nous en plateau jean
michel fourgous
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le deuxième
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge plus particulièrement
du développement économie des finances
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
je précise également que vous êtes le
maire de la ville d'elancourt première
question pourquoi lancer à 50 ans on y
mène ce salon l'événementiel parce que
on entend souvent en france
les politiques disent l'emploi l'emploi
l'emploi moi je connais avant l'emploi
je connais augmenter l'activité des
entreprises
ça c'est crédible ça manque une
comprenez l'économie déjà et l'emploi ça
vient après mais la première
préoccupation des hommes politiques se
doit être augmenté l'activité des
entreprises donc augmenter la croissance
du pig marchand donc il s'agit bien de
ça saint quentin c'est pas n'importe
quoi
c'est le deuxième pic par habitant en
france après paris c'est c'est donc la
huitième saison aussi d'innovations dans
le monde
après l'école il ya il ya un rôle
économique est vraiment assez
exceptionnel
il ya le projet du vous savez devenir
c'était
donc paris saclay qui serait la première
université française il ya plein de
choses il ya des évènements
extraordinaires qui arrive sur 7
sur cet espace de cinq ans maintenant
c'est important qu'il y ait cet
événement ya ne serait-ce que les jeux
olympiques qui fortes chances d'arriver
ici vous image et à l'activité que ça a
provoqué to know to know toutes nos
entreprises ont un certain devront être
mobilisés il y a bien sûr également
l'exposition universelle qui risque
d'arriver en 2024 quelques candidats
qu'est-ce que je vous rappelle que
effectivement en juillet vous avez
appris que c'était paris saclay sac a
notamment été choisi pour mettre
l'exposition universelle qui est le
symbole de promouvoir
l'attractivité française là le savoir
faire en termes de connaissances
scientifiques et techniques
ce sera je crois qu'il ya plus de 30
millions de visiteurs devrait vue il ya
20 milliards de chiffre en milliards
pour les 2 23 milliards l'héroïne les
landes de retombées économiques comme
vous le dites et 160 mille emplois qui
vont être une vision qui lui dit de vous
dire je vous passe la ryder cup qui
arrive dans un an mais dans un an
donc c'est une situation assez
exceptionnelle sur les jeux olympiques à
quatre sites qui sont dans notre donc
l'espace de saint quentin
donc bien sûr il faut une mobilisation
générale il faut toutes nos entreprises
un maximum de nos entreprises profitent
de ces retombées et développe augmente
intensifient leur activité
professionnelle leur événement bien sûr
alors c'est quoi un événement bas c'est
quelque chose qui va vous faire créer de
nouvelles animations de nouvelles
rencontres de nouveaux échanges
commerciaux puisque on augmente le
chiffre d'affaires en augmentant les
échanges commerciaux en trouvant de
nouveaux prospects de nouveaux clients
bien sûr on besoin de nouvelles
prestations donc là on va leur montrer
un peu ce qu'il ya de mieux puisque
saint quentin est là pour les
accompagner les aider faire de la veille
n'a même internationale sur ce qui
marche sur les innovations dont paul
andré landry et laisse donc vous avez
500 participants je vous avais plus de
60 exposants qu'ils vont montrer aux
entreprises comment quelque part un peu
augmenté leur chiffre d'affaires et
augmenter leur chiffre d'affaires ça
veut dire d'abord vous augmenter les
recettes aussi pour l'état pour les
collectivités donc il s'agit bien sûr
que tout le monde se sente sur le même
bateau france il bat au saint quentin en
yvelines ce n'est pas n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui c'est un plus à 20 minutes
de paris sans feux rouges sur certaines
parties de saint quentin en dehors des
enfants s'en va brûler nos nerfs mais il
demeure c'est pas mal donc c'est un et
là où c'est qu'on a eu en effet d'autres
événements on a fait le skype business
day qui est aussi un événement où on
active les rencontres entre les gros et
les petits sur le territoire de saint
quentin
donc oui beaucoup de manifestations
également sur l'argent puisqu'il est
entreposé le les sommes d'argent il faut
mettre et ça sera à chaque fois il faut
se tuer d'une manière conviviale c'est
aussi l'esprit du salon demain faire du
business de manière conviviale proposer
ses solutions clés en main c'est aussi
important ce bon esprit dans ce genre
d'événement oui il faut que l'esprit
business reviennent en france parce que
je vois pas que vous vous perdez 100
milliards quasiment par en france tout
le monde trouve ça normal et on s'en
fout c'est très grave
bien sûr qu'il faut il n'y a que la
relance bien sûr de l'activité de
l'entreprise
dans les heures ou jours et ça se passe
très bien entreprises françaises elle a
une très bonne image dans le monde donc
voila mais il faut les entrepreneurs ils
n'ont pas toujours le temps d'aller voir
toutes les innovations en terme
commercial en terme d'animations dont
voilà nous agglomération aussi de
participer à leur épanouissement à leur
dynamisme et leur faire gagner du temps
là dessus on est là pour leur simplifier
la vie leur apporter des solutions c'est
à vous de choisir mes shows cce
ça a laissé ses seules la confiance des
entrepreneurs peut créer de la
croissance
dernière chose jean michel fourgous vous
en avez parlé soixantaine une
soixantaine d'exposants pour ce sky
mazda et plein de deux structures qui
sont présentes sur l'agglomération je
pense à l'estac à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et notamment
le vélodrome nationale qui sera le
théâtre pour ses prochains jeux
olympiques 2000 24 voilà
nombreuses solutions finalement sur le
territoire pour organiser ces événements
oui de nombreuses solutions bi déjà
savoir que de savoir aussi que 50 est un
territoire ultra-connectés a déjà
puisque donc la fibre est quasiment en
train de se généraliser
donc il faut quand même toutes les
conditions je rappelle on a plus de
quinze mille entreprises 16600
exactement on a près de cent cinquante
mille emplois 145000 exactement donc
voilà il vous avez quand même vous avez
un territoire assez exceptionnel donc il
lui faut des méthodes aussi exceptionnel
est toujours essayer que toutes les
entreprises bénéficient des meilleures
prestations qu'elles soient bien au
courant que pour pour pour trouver un
client pour le fidéliser pour pour
également leurs collaborateurs pour
donner ou celle motiver ses
collaborateurs
c'est bien juste de conques c'est bien
mais c'est surtout toutes les toutes les
méthodes font pas les démotive et déjà
il est motivé quand tu rentres d'après
fo faut pas qu'il se fasse des métiers
et donc il y a aujourd'hui des méthodes
de renforcement bien sûr et c'est c'est
tout cela que l'on met à disposition de
nos entreprises du territoire de sympa
et d'ailleurs si vous voulez plus
d'information sur ce salon il ya le site
internet 1 www.skype.com faire je
précise que l'entrée est gratuite sur
inscription et que des navettes
gratuites seront au départ de paris et
de saint quentin en yvelines merci jean
michel fourgous d'avoir été avec notre
exclusive deuxième vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines et le sky news
day 1c demain à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux 2010 à 20h c'est
probable probablement la mesure phare de
la rentrée et qui marque les ambitions
aide emmanuel macron pour l'éducation le
dédoublement des classes de cp dans les
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire
renforcer objectif douze élèves par
classe maximum pour mieux apprendre à
lire écrire compter et respecter autrui
selon le souhait du ministère de
l'éducation et nicolas le département
des yvelines est concerné par ce
dispositif
en effet grégory dans le département le
dédoublement des classes du cp concerne
depuis lundi 4 septembre un peu moins de
élève vous le voyez à l'écran répartis
dans 100 4 classes dans le département
soit 30 école précisément concernés qui
sont situés dans cinq villes vous les
voyez aussi s'afficher à l'écran et
parmi ces villes on retrouve la commune
de trappes quatre écoles élémentaires
sont concernés attrape la ville a donc
dû travailler de façon assez active cet
été pour créer neuf nouvelles classes
pour répondre à cette demande du
dédoublement du cp écoutez à ce propos
jeanine marie délégué première adjointe
au maire en charge de l'éducation
justement attrape au nouveau remplir
notre mission nous avions juste sur les
trois réseaux un seul réseau plus c'est
celui de youri gagarine et nous avons pu
dédoubler les cp comme c'était comme
c'était prévu par le ministre ça n'a pas
été compliqué parce que nous avions des
classes disponibles donc que nous avons
pris sur ses classes ce qui fait que les
enfants ont une classe chacun vu les
difficultés de nos enfants est là en
seniors à davantage de temps pour chacun
d'eux or nicolas pas de problème
important pour la mise à en place
attraper ce que est ce que c'est le cas
partout dans les yvelines est ce que ça
veut dire que tout le monde salue cette
mesure alors selon les chiffres
communiqués par les services
départementaux de l'académie de
versailles
84% des classes concernées ont pu être
dédoublé et sans problème apparent en
tout cas en apparence pour accueillir
douze élèves au maximum dans les 16 %
restants en revanche les responsables
d'établissements dû faire preuve
d'imagination et réorganiser les salles
pour accueillir deux professeurs par
exemple dans une même classe c'est l'une
des solutions imaginées et ce côté un
peu précipité de la réforme que les
syndicats dénoncent ils sont ok sur le
fond ils le sont au bouc ou moins sur la
forme et continue notamment de pointé du
doigt le manque de personnel écoutez là
aussi 75% des élèves qui sont ciblés par
ce type de mesures ne sont ni aurait
plus ni même en éducation prioritaire
donc cela n'en bénéficieront pas et vous
avez dans toutes les classes des élèves
qui sont en difficulté ou en très grande
difficulté et qui eux ne bénéficieront
pas d'une baisse des effectifs en cp
d'autre part
ccp dédoubler se font sur des
redéploiements de personnels
en aucun cas il n'a été prévu de créer
des postes
donc c'est à dire que ce redéploiement
de personnel veut dire que l'on va
déshabiller quelque part l'école de
certaines de ses missions pour habiller
ccpd doublé au qu'il en soit du court et
gorée il faudra attendre au moins à la
fin de cette année scolaire pour savoir
si ce dispositif est efficace
je vous rappelle qu'il vise un taux de
100% pour l'acquisition des savoirs
fondamentaux lire écrire compter
et puis la nouveauté de la rentrée c'est
aussi respecter autrui et il faut
rappeler aussi que sa mise en place va
s'accélérer d'ici la rentrée 2010 neuf
dans deux ans ce sont l'ensemble des cp
et ce1 cette fois-ci situés en zone
d'éducation prioritaire qui devront être
dédoublé selon une nouvelle fois les
ambitions du ministère merci nicolas
pour ces précisions
c'est un univers qui fait souvent
révélés plus petit celui des pompiers
pour tenter de le rendre réel la ville
de plaisir organise tous les étés des
stages découverte pour les 8 13 ans
hier soir se tenait la cérémonie de
remise de récompenses sujet de nicolas
kirilow liszt
[Musique]
diplôme à la main sourire aux lèvres
devant leurs camarades de promotion et
leurs parents près d'une cinquantaine
d'enfants de plaisir et ses environs se
voient récompensés de leurs efforts ils
ont participé durant l'été à un stage de
trois jours avec les sapeurs-pompiers
plaisir wa un stage en forme de rêve
pour beaucoup d'entre eux et pour se
mettre dans la peau d'un professionnel
la grande échelle on a fait
on a fait une fois c'est une bataille
d'eau et c'était c'était bien parce que
monsieur salle et nous a arrosé voilà on
a pris les numéros d'appel d'urgence
on est monté une grande échelle à 30
mètres on a fait du rappel on est allé
dans un bar où c'est une sorte de derby
rap dans le noir mis en place par la
mairie de plaisir depuis 15 ans en
partenariat avec le centre secours local
ces stages estivaux ont surtout une
portée pédagogique respect efforts
physiques notamment permet de mieux
répercuter certains enseignements
le premier objectif c'est de faire un
lien entre la population le plaisir et
des environs avec le métier de sapeur
pompier pour que la population comprenne
dès le plus jeune âge une omission le
après un autre objectif c'est de leur
apprendre nous dans notre rôle de
prévention
c'est de leur apprendre de leur faire
passer des messages de prévention sur le
numéro de téléphone d'urgence sur les
premiers gestes à réaliser lors d'une
intervention d'urgence de nouvelles
sessions sont prévues l'été prochain les
inscriptions débuteront en juin et d'ici
là les jeunes stagiaires pourront
diffuser leurs connaissances à l'école
faire travailler les producteurs
franciliens et promouvoir le bio credo
établi par lippi de la vallée c'est à
saint-aubin dans le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
l'épicerie participative propose des
produits locaux 75% de ses partenaires
commerciaux sont situées à 20 km à la
ronde
zoom avec mathilde denis là aussi c'est
l'agriculteur qui fait ses propres pâte
à partir de son blé du miel local
puisqu'il vient de villiers-le-bâcle
manger bio c'est bien les manger bio et
local c'est mieux ces véhicules les prix
de la vallée épicerie participative a
mis en place en janvier dernier pour
rassembler les agriculteurs de la région
le but c'est de manger plus local
premièrement et de manger si c'est
possible plus bio donc l'idée c'est de
se fournir localement en produits qui
existent
alors quand ils existent parce qu'en
région parisienne tout n'existe pas mais
donc par exemple on travaille avec le
fournil de villiers le bâcle qui est ici
tout près qui nous fournit du pain bio
la particularité de l'épi de la vallée
c'est que étant donné que comme je
voulais dit la main d'oeuvre est fournie
par les adhérents les matériaux sont
issus de la récupération on ne met
aucune marge sur les produits donc le
prix que nous payons aux agriculteurs
aux anneaux fournisseurs divers et
variés c'est le prix que
que nous vendons à nos adhérents pour
information les trois produits qui
partent le plus ici à l'épicé la bière
le chocolat et le papier toilette une
adhésion à l'association à partir de 30
euros qui permet d'accéder à des
produits frais et locaux
une nouvelle alimentation qui séduit de
plus en plus les yvelinois et les
essonniens c'est quelque chose en fait
que les gens veulent maintenant ils
veulent manger différemment ils veulent
manger local davantage bio riz pâtes
confiture lessive une épicerie qui
contient entre 200 et 300 produits des
aliments que l'on peut trouver à l'épi
de la vallée sans passer par le
supermarché on est cinq à la maison je
fais quasiment toutes mes courses à
l'épi gcc quasiment d'aller ailleurs
il manque des choses on n'a pas de
brosse à dents évidemment que je
continue d'aller dans le commerce
traditionnel pour les brosses à dents on
a du dentifrice en poudre mais bon il
fait pas l'unanimité à la maison il ya
évidemment des choses qui m'a envoyé 200
1 300 produits de base s'est pas
beaucoup mais moi je m'arrange il ya des
choses que je ne je n'achète plus parce
qu'elles sont pas les pays et qu'elles
sont pas nécessaires un nouveau mode de
vie plus rustique qui fait participer
les différents acteurs de la région
des épis qui n'en finissent plus de
pousser ce sont sûrement des phrases que
vous avez entendu enfants lorsque vous
parliez du métier de vos rêves
franchement tu te pose trop de questions
ou encore le traditionnel bah c'est
comme ça tu n'as pas le choix
liouize noise odile crouïgneau a réussi
à la surmonter ces barrières elle
raconte comment dans son spectacle aux
et gagner votre vie sans la perdre
c'est à voir les 10 et 11 novembre
prochain au théâtre de la contrescarpe à
paris est mise en scène signée robert
poujade au jeu vous propose de voir un
extrait cité pour l'instant ingénieurs
site et ingénieur a du boulot si tu as
tu voulu montrer là
si tu as de l'argent c'est que c'est
intelligent si tu es intelligent c'est
que c'est mathieu ici tma-20 et voilà
c'est comme ça ça vient pas d'un iota
ben c'est bien un truc dans français
fous royalement c'est alors qu'elles
sont audrey ge et nos talents et par
mois c'est à ça que je suis la deuxième
catégorie malgré tout vers explications
je me pose encore des questions
et pour parler de ce spectacle avec tous
sur ce plateau bien sûr son auteur odile
crouïgneau bonsoir alors vous êtes
artiste coach entrepreneurs une
formation métier assez atypique mais on
peut le dire vous exercer le métier de
vos rêves
oui c'est un métier de mes rêves que
j'ai créée de toute pièce parce
qu'effectivement artistes coach
entrepreneurs ça n'existait pas et je
pense qu'en fait beaucoup enfin il ya
beaucoup de métiers qui vont de voir
éclore et qu'on va avoir à inventer jeu
pas d'ici 2030
il ya au moins 60% des métiers qui sont
des nouveaux métiers
donc voila moi j'ai créé le mien et je
l'appelle artistes coach entrepreneurs
parce qu'effectivement j'ai entendu
toute mon enfance que statistiquement il
fallait pas rêver que si on était qu'il
fallait être matheux d'ailleurs pour
être et scientifique est plutôt
cartésien et rationnelle pour gagner sa
vie
pour avoir une chance de réussir à
gagner sa vie voilà réussir gagner sa
vie sauf qu'en fait ce qu'on oublie
c'est que c'est peut-être pas un scoop
mais on n'a pas tous les mêmes cerveaux
et qu'il ya des gens qui sont faits pour
être heureux en étant atteint il ya des
gens qui sont qui peuvent être matin
qu'ils peuvent apprendre ça c'est sûr
mais qui en fait sont heureux en étant
autre chose que mateu et ça c'est mon
cas et donc
mon spectacle aux et gagner votre vie
sans la perdre c'est vraiment pour dire
que ça fait 200 ans effectivement c'est
la révolution industrielle qu'on a tous
formatés en mode industriel parce qu'on
se disait mais il faut des ingénieurs
pour reconstruire pour construire les
infrastructures etc et aujourd'hui en
fait c'est la révolution numérique donc
ce dont on a le plus besoin la
compétence dont on a le plus besoin
c'est la créativité et donc être artiste
c'est enfin avoir cette créativité dans
sa vie professionnelle
ça c'était voilà moi mon rêve à moi je
sais pas si c'est d'être artiste en tant
que tel mais c'était d'avoir trois
choses dans la vie professionnelle c'est
d'abord d'être créative c'est à dire
d'avoir du plaisir dans ce que je fais
deuxièmement de contribuer plus tôt à la
beauté du monde qu'elles sont arides
issement trouver du sens dans ce que je
fais dans ma vie professionnelle
et troisièmement gagner ma vie gagner ma
vie avec mon luxe à moi je demande pas
forcément gagner des millions mais
gagner ma vie est ici vous à moitié ce
justement à monter sur scène pour faire
partager cette expérience et aider
peut-être des gens qui étaient dans la
même situation vous c'est justement ça
j'ai envie de transmettre mon message
parce que moi ce qui a vraiment changé
ma vie j'ai cherché j'ai vraiment
beaucoup cherché dans tous les sens
c'est plutôt dans le mauvais sens
d'ailleurs en cherchant à comprendre
pourquoi ça marchait pas ce qu'il
fallait que je fasse des différents et
en réalité c'est chercher à comprendre
à voir comment ça va marcher
neurobiologiques mans aujourd'hui on le
sait la visualisation créatrice c'est
extrêmement puissant et ça je vais
découvert ans nous formons coaching et
voilà est donc ce qui est c'est en
formant au coaching je me suis rendu
compte que déjà pour moi ça m'aidait à
réaliser grève les uns après les autres
et du coup j'ai eu envie de transmettre
aussi ça parce que j'ai envie de
transmettre et je trouve qu'il ya
tellement de talent et de créativité
dans ce monde que c'est tellement
dommage qu'elle se soit pas valorisé au
sens figuré mais aussi aussi au sens
propre qu'on puisse être entrepreneur
avec cette créativité alors d'ailleurs à
ce spectacle est aussi une conférence à
vous donner des solutions aux personnes
qui y viennent vous voir j'avais envie
de vous poser une dernière question ce
que le temps malheureusement viendra
sceller le but finalement
que doit se dire le spectateur une fois
qu'il est sorti de votre spectacle est
ce qu'il doit y avoir un déclic en lui
c'est ça aussi la question est épié
jusque que doit-il il ya surtout pas de
voir je peux penser du plaisir pur mais
ce que j'ai envie de promouvoir dans ce
spectacle c'est vraiment que chacun
effectivement sortent du spectacle en
étant un peu plus heureux que il n'y est
entré et avait une petite clé je fais
faire des exercices aux spectacteurs qui
sont des spectacteurs qui deviennent
acteurs de leur projet et ils sortent
avec une petite pépite pour leurs
projets merci odile lecrosnier merci
avec nous votre spectacle aux et gagner
votre vie sans la perdre et à voir les
10 et 11 novembre à 20h au théâtre de la
contrescarpe arpa à paris réservations
sur le portail billetreduc et votre
actualité est à consulter sur votre site
internet qui s'affiche pour nos
téléspectateurs
les cougars folle auront bientôt leur
nouveau terrain c'est du sport l'équipe
de baseball de montigny le bretonneux va
bénéficier d'un stade rénové pour la
prochaine saison
elle les travaux commencés en juillet
concerne le revêtement la pose du
revêtement d'un terrain synthétique
dernière génération
le point avec le sportif de cette
rédaction michael et demi d'euros le
stade jean marc et celle de montigny le
bretonneux et en plein lifting la ville
a déboursé près de six cent quarante
deux mille euros pour rénover les
terrains de la structure pendant
l'intersaison le synthétique daté du
début des années 2000 on va avoir quand
même un cas de synthétique de qualité
conforme à l'usagé baseball
chose qui n'était pas forcément évident
sur l'ancienne moquette
bon après on a aussi les normes qui
évolue régulièrement donc là on sera
vraiment à jour des dernières normes
commencé à être usé les joueurs
partaient avec une grande partie du
terrain dans leurs chaussettes tous les
soirs après les matches après les
entraînements
et puis surtout il était devenu très dur
et ça commençait à leur donner mal au
genou après avoir débuté en juillet des
travaux qui devaient s'achever en août
ont pris du retard
la livraison définitive est finalement
programmée d'ici fin septembre
des délais qui ont poussé le club des
cougars de monti le bretonneux à jouer
leur quart de finale des play-off de d1
contre paris à l'extérieur il vaut mieux
attendre et puis avoir quelque chose qui
correspondait tout à fait à nos attentes
et je pense que
vu ce que l'on nous a dit que nous
allions avoir ça va correspondre
forcément une fois terminée la structure
accueillera entre 180 et 200 joueurs par
semaine et des groupes scolaires et on
referme ce journal avec ses belles
images celles des grandes zones
nocturnes qui ont égayé les soirées du
samedi cet été au château de versailles
au programme deux heures 30 de balade
féerique dans les jardins et mise en eau
et lumière au son de la musique baroque
il vous reste encore deux samedis pour
profiter du spectacle offre 2 52 euros
pour les familles de quatre personnes
c'est la fin de ce journal tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile la tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]